this video is sponsored by the great
courses plus when I think over the
weirdest of all things I can think of
you know what it is
nothing Alan Watts linguistically and
conceptually we know that nothing is the
absence of a thing or things in a
particular space we might say that there
is nothing in a glass when we mean that
there is no liquid we might say that
there is nothing in a room when we mean
that there is no stuff and we might say
that there is nothing in a vacuum of
space when we mean that there is no
matter or atoms at all however true
absolute nothing is perhaps something
else entirely true nothingness might be
nothing more than an abstract idea that
doesn't really mean anything outside of
language or perhaps it might be a
fundamental quality of all reality a
void with a function for obvious reasons
physics and quantum field theory look
towards empty space as a definition or
understanding of nothingness one could
study empty space by taking a fully
sealed metal container and sucking out
all of the air inside would then become
a vacuum void of all atoms and molecules
but when particle physicists do this and
probe of vacuum the space still actually
contains quantum mechanical properties
these properties have the minimum
possible energy a system can have and
are in what is known as a zero-point
energy state which involves local
quantum fields and virtual particles but
the point is there is not nothing there
are things going on with measurable
properties consequently all the empty
space of the universe isn't really
nothing
as a result science doesn't really take
much interest into what true nothingness
is and what it's metaphysical
implications might be because science
doesn't really care about what it can't
measure because how could it but that
doesn't necessarily make it any less
relevant to everything in the words of
theoretical physicist Sean Carol it's
probably better to think of nothing as
the absence of even space and time
rather than space and time without
anything in them to try to consider this
sort of true nothing as in to try to
imagine the subtraction of everything in
the entire universe including time and
space itself one could theoretically do
this and picture a sort of stark
lack void but of course one would still
be left with themselves considering the
absence of everything and thus by
defining or imagining this one is still
ascribing a somethingness to nothingness
I thought a concept not nothing
naturally because of the dissonance and
strangeness of such an idea nothing this
can be rather intriguing terrifying or
both also of course for some the mere
verbal construction of the concept of
nothing is enough to reduce the entire
validity of the idea into absurdity to
try to understand nothing sounds
obscenely unnecessary and foolish and it
might be but what isn't then to question
why or how anything is is at bottom to
eventually question everything and to
question why and how everything is is at
bottom to eventually question
nothingness when followed to their end
all inquiries ultimately lead to the
questions why is there something rather
than nothing how and is there nothing
beyond it
many of the significant philosophers of
history like Parmenides Immanuel Kant
Hegel Soren Kierkegaard Martin Heidegger
jean-paul Sartre and many more as well
as many religious and spiritual ideas
suggested in Buddhism Taoism and the
very essence of God as well as research
areas in science especially that of
physics and quantum field theory all
focus at least some of their discourse
effort and intrigue on the mystifying
potential relevance of nothing arguably
in some faint strange sensorial way
throughout moments of our life we have
likely all come in contact with a sort
of metaphysical nothingness many
philosophers like Soren Kierkegaard
Martin Heidegger and John Paul Sartre
suggested that we sense the nothingness
through moods like anxiety dread or
dizzying nausea
a sort of premonition or awareness of
the thin veneer and emptiness behind
everything we might feel this when we
are alone at night having trouble
falling asleep or during a strange
moment while having a meal or watching
TV or when we are somewhere out in
public and something comes up that
instills a certain anxiety in which we
seem to suddenly realize that this all
sort of just showed up out of nothing
and that we will all be returning to
that and if that's the case what is that
nothing
just on the other side of our skull or
underneath everything we perceive as
real what really is that what could
possibly be the absence of all things
time and space we might contrive all
sorts of ideas for an afterlife but we
have no reason to believe afterlife is
anything different from what came before
it if our consciousness is infinite and
there is an afterlife then our same
consciousness would have had to proceed
before this life which no one could
possibly claim as a self identifying
person the philosophical view known as
idealism posits that reality is in some
necessary way linked with and dependent
on cognitive perception and the
understanding of ideas this is not
necessarily to say that the physical
matter of one's body or things outside
of one's body occur only in
consciousness but that one's knowledge
of their reality only occurs in
consciousness and thus their reality is
interdependent on consciousness even if
one doesn't agree with idealism one
could still likely agree with the
premise that our mind creates or allows
our sense and experience of being and so
if our mind and consciousness are lost
upon death then we were faced with an on
being of reality a point at which we
could no longer even imagine everything
in the universe being removed because as
the imaginer we would be to this of
course would potentially be the absolute
nothing it is strange and rather
terrifying to consider this that we can
be something for now and nothing forever
but perhaps only because of the fact
that we are nothing forever can we be
something for now a negation of all
other things across all other time and
space being amidst everything else and
nothing more and perhaps only because of
which we are something right now
following some semblance of the
metaphysical train of thought of the
20th century German philosopher Martin
Heidegger as well as the 20th century
french philosopher jean-paul sartre the
nothing comes first
nothingness precedes consciousness and
the conscious act of negating or
imagining nothing as an act that has
derived from the nothingness in other
words the non being acts on being
allowing the intellect to negate
everything except itself back to it for
example by self identifying ourselves as
ourselves
we have determined that we are ourself -
everything else which is to also say we
are who we are and nothing else
our total sum of perceptions and
understandings all determined through
the same process of negating every
individual thing from everything else
consolidates into the last and final
negation of self-knowledge nothing isn't
the opposite of being nor what
everything comes from per se but what
allows something to be at all to
potentially deviate from any specific
philosophers train of thought it is
possible that nothing doesn't
necessarily create everything but rather
serves as the backdrop that allows
everything like a blank canvas is to a
painting nothingness is to the being of
the canvas itself likewise to the
painter painting and every particle
involved it could then follow that at
the risk of more seemingly rhetorical
wordplay everything and nothing are one
in simultaneous interlocked coordination
with one another everything contained by
nothing nothing supposed by everything
the blank canvas - the painting the
empty glass the glass of water the empty
room to the bedroom the nothingness -
all space and time
- you in the words of Alan Watts so in
this way by seeing that nothingness is
the fundamental reality and you see it's
your reality then how can anything
contaminate you all the idea of you
being scared and put out and worried and
so on is just nothing it's a dream
because you're really nothing but this
is the most incredible nothing so cheer
up
you see when we are tuned into this
nothingness of being and truly
confronted as a potentially equal part
it could and likely should be followed
with a deep recognition of the thin
temporariness coated over everything and
thus the importance of focusing not on
some ultimate endgame goal but on the
very real implications that there are
none that the ever fleeting present is
all there is slid through us at the
intersection of the mystical oneness of
all things and nothing and perhaps as
such we should try our best to be
careful of what we take seriously and
don't
as long as we are we cannot escape the
everything that is created through us
norther nothing that we created it from
this very creative intuition fills the
poetry and art and literature and
philosophies and religions and Sciences
and perhaps the general history of
everything past and yet to come a
passion a longing a meaning and anxiety
a dread a synergy with the same mystery
that lit the stars we all share in this
transient retreat to and from and
through nothing and thus in the most
rhetorically ironic yet beautiful way we
are all connected by nothing we might
never know what nothing is until we know
nothing at all and even then we might
not we are free to imagine nothing how
we like because if nothingness is in
fact the source and destiny that
connects us all through which perhaps
anything is possible this video was
sponsored by the great courses plus with
lifelong education being incredibly
important but sometimes challenging to
find the right means to sustain the
great courses plus makes it easy and
accessible through their subscription
based on demand video learning platform
on which you can find a curated
inventory of over 11,000 video lectures
covering a wide variety of subjects in
science philosophy literature arts and
much more with content provided by
professors from Ivy League's and top
universities around the world as well as
experts from places like National
Geographic and the Smithsonian lectures
are at a university level with reliable
and comprehensive insights that satisfy
basically anyone's scope of interests if
you're interested in learning about
different systems and theories of
Western philosophy one great course
worth checking out is titled modern
intellectual tradition from Descartes to
Derrida the courses taught by professor
of philosophy Lawrence Cahoon who
provides a dense but digestible overview
of Western philosophical thinking its
key epistemological and metaphysical
ideas and the individual philosophers
who have helped build it into what it is
today you could start your free trial of
the great courses plus by visiting the
great courses plus.com slash pursuit of
wonder or by clicking the link in the
description below of course thank you so
much
watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]